right I always used to say look at this
family selfish right had had to go on
vacation and had to bring the kid now I
feel completely different because now
I'm in those shoes and I'm like I
sympathize I know of a story where the
higher profile couple sat in first and
their child sat with the nanny in the
back now you think of that that's just
bad parent right I agree I think that's
horrible you it was your it's your child
yeah it wasn't Sebastian I swear
that's comedian Sebastian Maniscalco and
his family pediatrician Dr Scott Cohen
talking to singer Meghan Trainor about
traveling with her kids we should say
Megan wasn't the celebrity couple that
would sit in the front I thought that
was so bad Scott give us names
Sebastian give us names Sebastian sis
with his kids yes that's good this is
from the premiere of their new podcast
Daddy versus doctor they're back with us
now you also on that tape Sebastian say
that you went and bought all this
chocolate to sort of say to the Past
preemptive look we're going to be
traveling please forgive us and when you
went to offer it to one passenger they
said nope we don't want the chocolate
yeah they they declined the chocolate
and then I came back to my wife and she
goes how'd it go I go could you believe
someone denied my little chocolate gift
so uh yeah I was pretty offended that
they did that I thought
that's
that's I'm friends with the pediatrician
I don't think the pediatrician wants to
be my friend so you guys were already
friends were you friends well we became
friends through the office okay which is
a general rule not to do but yeah he
stalked me a little bit kept calling for
dates yeah well listen when I first met
him he came into the hospital to check
on Seraphina and I go is this guy even
old enough
Doogie Howser
five years ago I was like yeah but and
he had cologne on I go is it is it right
for the pediatrician to be wearing
cologne that protocol I want your baby
to smell like me so he reminds you of me
you know go home so and did you say
after that Scott did you say the two of
us have something here how did you know
we have a genius what you're doing well
being friends it makes it really easy
because he makes everything relatable
yeah and I always thought you know
parenting is that one genre of medicine
that we're all in the same boat you know
everything that happens as a parent for
the first time is anxiety producing it's
scary you just wonder am I doing it
right then you realize that every
parent's going through the same thing at
the exact same time but we don't talk
about it although you know who was not
going through it at the same time our
fathers right there's a generational
difference between what the men at this
table do with their kids and what our
parents did just what the expectations
were so I think it's important this is
from the dad's perspective what you guys
are doing no I appreciate that and then
people can call in have a laugh because
we really need to laugh about what we're
going through as parents it's funny that
the poop is green we've all been to
Google you know University you get 100
page Pages the most esoteric answers but
the last one is everything's okay during
that process it causes a lot of stress
and anxiety so let's have a laugh let's
get some good education on being a
parent and have fun with it yeah
Sebastian uh we know that you're one of
the funniest yes individuals in the
business but you do bring humor to this
like doctor is saying
um why is that important for you though
to take the laughter from the stage into
your home well uh in my home I'm I'm the
worry Ward I'm constantly worrying about
stuff and and for example I would think
you would have been the chill one no no
for example
give the kid grapes right now I found
out that grapes through Dr Cohen are
number one reason for choking am I
correct on that yeah big big joke yeah
okay I'm taking the grapes now and I'm
cutting them like onion onions so
they're they're basically this small so
I find these little things like this my
my constant worry funny yeah and other
parents out there could go oh my God
yeah I do that or I do yeah so I'm
trying to take the comedy and relate it
to Parenting and people need to laugh
this is supposed to be fun you're right
so I do the grape thing too and then the
the Judgment call comes on the blueberry
is the blueberry too big or does it need
to be cut it's just mush a little bit I
worry more about the skin of the
blueberry okay and the size I know I do
a little mush I was always scared you do
an individual motion each blueberry on
the table my daughter's 14 and 12 now so
that'd be a little weird
you draw from the way you were raised by
your dad your dad is also always
Incorporated in your act yes what he's
done for you and you think I want to do
that or I want to do something totally
different my dad didn't start pairing
and parenting until I was 8 18. I think
that's when he came into the scene he
was working my uh my childhood so and we
were talking about it earlier we're
parenting different than our parents you
know as my dad really wasn't the worrier
my mom was so uh yeah my father my
father started in later on in life as
far as his advice and you were engaged
from day one weren't you I was engaged
from day one I mean I was uh yeah I was
on the floor yeah I'm on the floor I'm
you know I'm one of these dads that
likes to participate in the in the child
rearing so uh one more bit of news uh
people can use here one of the debates
in my household also something comes up
on the playground uh my daughter will
eat sand yeah she's a fourth child so
I'm good with the the sand eating other
parents are not good they are not good
they're tapping me on the shoulder
they're telling me it's happening that
isn't good they're constantly and I'm
so the question is is it okay that she's
eating sand and moderate everything in
moderation right have you tasted it the
real reason this relationships to happen
let's be honest has nothing to do with
the kids it's so he can text me and ask
me questions about himself his hip his
back
he's like seraphina's got a fever oh and
by the way I got this
[Laughter]
that's how you double dip yeah
differently you both think oh yeah my my
wife is you know do whatever you want
you know throw them up in the air and
I'm like this this you know let's take
it down a notch all right you don't do
the toss you know the oh I know people
that they're throwing the kid up
everything I got a picture of them
the camera yeah my wife's a
disciplinarian did you know your parents
had that look yeah that you knew not to
do it yes I I don't have that well when
I give my girls the look they laugh at
me a wife has the look for them and me
but you kind of got so yeah that face
Sebastian I know you have that they
laugh at no I know listen I I am the
disciplinarian so I do have that look
when I'm I'm running the house like a
military Camp there you go so if they do
something here's the look
there are new episodes of daddy versus
doctor every Friday and Sebastian
Maniscalco and Dr Scott Cohen we'll join
CBS mornings real soon
don't go anywhere they'll be right back